hello and welcome to the simulation I am
your host Alex all can thank you so much
for coming out for this evening a
thought-provoking conversation a I
genetic engineering colonizing Mars
neural prosthetics we will be talking
about it all tonight with our guests for
the evening and the forge using him I
want to thank our epic facility our
venue for the evening it is the factory
is it incredible or what on a pink card
your sponsor black hammer brewing have
you guys been enjoying that and wild
pepper our food sponsor enjoying that as
well
good all right good stuff good stuff so
we're live-streaming this so if you have
friends that want to hear about this
conversation that are unable to tune in
live please go to the simulation
Facebook page and just share that to
them it's also being streamed on my page
as well Allen sake on so just a little
bit of background this idea is to put
global leaders with humanity's no stop
provoking questions on the same stage we
hope to inspire people to build the
future of civilization that sounds fun
[Music]
yeah so so checks check this our goal
and with your support we will actually
get there our goal is to by 2019 after
the Super Bowl we want to rent we want
to rent Levi's Stadium out and we want
to put fifty thousand scientists and
engineers and designers in the audience
and we want to have Elon Musk and Mark
Zuckerberg and other global leaders
discussing these questions and without
further ado I will introduce to you our
guests for the evening evening hey sack
to having me Audrey it is very nice to
have you and Aubrey was the first person
to introduce me to how everyone is in a
pro aging trance
are you familiar with that oh you got a
head tell us well they're probably
actually first of all tell me do I need
to use this microphone since I have this
microphone yes because so look around
you
everyone thinks that death is inevitable
so true
so it's not inevitable and I'm very
inspired by people like Aubrey that very
quickly teach people about getting out
of this pro-beijing
trance that we can live forever yeah
okay that wasn't very good so one part
one part of it
do you like cancer do you like
Alzheimer's do you like people dying in
your family all right so better all
right so all right so so that the term
prior aging trance which I coined a long
time ago now is basically the
psychological state in which one defends
the concept of aging for a completely
irrational reasons like for example
saying oh well you know the diseases of
old age just obviously bad but there's
this other thing called
aging itself but it's fine and a good
thing it was a blessing in disguise and
all that or you know well we put all the
people or wouldn't dictators live
forever if we didn't have aging things
like that you know this is what I call
the pro aging trance and the reason I
call it that is because I have been I
have had the fortune to see people who
are in an actual trans have been
hypnotized and who are caused to believe
something that isn't true and to
justifies to explain it it could we also
potentially make this analogous to white
3 that I'll come to that so so the thing
about people who are hypnotized and told
to believe something that isn't true and
then asked to explain it is they can
they're very very good at it or at least
they think they are they
give utterance as it ating fluent lucid
explanations for the idiotic thing that
they have been caused to believe and
they have no idea that what they're
saying is idiotic
absolutely not I was first exposed to
this in fact I am the only time I've
really been
to a first hand with when I was in my
early 20s as an undergraduate in
Cambridge in England and it stayed with
me it was very powerful and when I
started to converse with people about
their attitudes towards aging I was very
forcefully reminded of this so that's
where the phrase came from
now you mentioned powered flight so this
is an interesting guy he can't get to
Mars we can't get to even the moon we
can't so this is sometimes a little
oversimplified you cannot go out and say
well look people have been over
pessimistic about this or that
technological challenge in the past
therefore we're obviously over
pessimistic about the defeat ability of
ageing no that's not fair you can't say
that you can equally say the opposite
what you can't say is we can't be sure
yeah you can certainly say people were
over pessimistic about powered flight no
people have latest 1900 or later we're
saying that it was theoretically
impossible right up until the Wright
brothers did it but equally you know
rather smart people like Leonardo da
Vinci
you know like 400 years earlier we're
saying that we were quite close and they
were wrong too in the opposite direction
so we can't be sure right but we don't
need to be sure in order to justify
really trying really hard because even
if we have a small chance of actually no
it's succeeding with what we know today
in hastening the defeat of our biggest
problem the thing that causes the most
suffering in the world we damn well
ought to be going to that chance yes
all right you just not want to live
forever all right who thinks that the
question of whether how long you want to
live in a [ __ ] up stupid question yeah
I mean the reason I say it's a [ __ ] up
stupid question it's very
straightforward to explain hands up
anyone who has an opinion about what
time they want to go to the toilet next
Monday there you go now there's no
reason why you don't have an opinion you
might have no pain about what time you
expect to go to the time they could have
have it right that's different what I'm
talking about what time you want to go
to the toilet who would have an opinion
about that I mean that was completely
crazy right there's a reason it's crazy
we all know the reason why it's crazy to
have an opinion about that namely that
we're gonna have better information on
the topic near at the time and we're
gonna be able to act on that better
information right so what's the point of
knowing that of thinking about it now
right it's exactly the same I haven't
the faintest idea whether I want to live
to a hundred but I don't need to know I
just made I do like I do want to know
because I want to see the humanity get
for that I want to see his progress well
you know what got to progress because of
people that care about building the
future building a great world and I
think that that love and that increase
in consciousness is slowly going to
overcome hatred and suffering and those
things you might be right and you might
be wrong but the point is that that I
mean I agree with you but we might be
wrong we might be wrong yeah yeah right
but the point is
yeah but the point is if you don't have
an opinion it's still fine because you
can just have an opinion about wanting
to carry on having a lot of choice
that's what I have right I just don't
want my option about whether to live to
a hundred or a thousand to be
progressively taken away from me by my
declining health yeah now that's a
bleeding obvious thing so 150 you just
don't want it to be taken away from you
you don't want the choice tech-noir
that's right the choice take good okay
this is a good start now we have a bowl
of questions they're written on index
cards they're the ones that operate
picked for today from the list
it's simulation series calm for / of the
- list if you want to see the list of
all 100 of these thought provoking
questions and there will be iterated on
over time if you guys want to submit the
answers or some answers the questions
welcome to if you want to submit
questions you're welcome to so we're
well this is a little mixing basic do
you believe that love is harder than
rocket science first thing you gotta
remember is that I chose the questions I
didn't write the question
I had to choose a a respectable number
from the less than Island Road I
actually did complain at the first
iteration I said no [ __ ] but but I
fixed that most of it was my problem
with the first iteration was that the
questions are all of the form what most
of them were of the form do you believe
in they saw that which I didn't think
myself but at least the current random
questions are do you believe something
ok so do I believe that love is harder
than rocket science
well I've certainly made a lot of
mistakes
when it comes to my personal life then
again I've also made a lot of non
mistakes and I've ended up in a pretty
good position overall I've never tried
rocket science so I can't honestly say
how it is but I you know I believe that
the work I do do and the work I used to
do in artificial intelligence it's
probably about as hard rocket science
and I didn't make that many mistakes in
those areas so yeah I look over the
answer yes alright what do you guys
think is love harder than rocket science
round of applause
all right I want another gender ratio on
that one or how many of them are in
relationships okay cool so without even
me providing thoughts about it just yeah
one thing one thing whether I mean about
the gender thing one thing I mean I'm
because I'm being so I mean decidedly
flippant here but the fact is you know
sometimes I have to be Justin or not to
cry when I get ask stupid questions one
of the questions I often get asked that
I find particularly secure it is why do
you want to live forever because the
fact is you know longevity is a side
effect of what we actually work on and
will I actually care about namely health
right so it's a ridiculous question and
I've been telling people with two
ridiculous questions for a very very
long time so it's a bit frustrating that
people don't get it so what I'm feeling
particularly flippant what I say well
look it takes the best part of a
currently normal lifetime for a guy to
figure out what women like and dislike
about men so if I live like you know a
thousand years then maybe I've got a
shot at figuring out what women like and
dislike about each other yeah but as I
said we've been clipping with within
love what I find interesting is that
humans are the first species to
celebrate lifelong monogamy with a
wedding type celebration I don't know
I've never seen monkeys or other species
throw away my massive weddings so anyway
is it harder than rocket science you'll
be remembered a lot of these answers to
these questions are not binary yes-or-no
they're discourse that we have and so
let's move on to the next question
for this one for this one we will go
ahead that was do you believe we are
alone son that's likely treat here
because I haven't known another question
in the bucket and said something like do
you believe we are in a simulation and I
don't have the faintest idea whether
we're in a simulation there are various
good arguments that say we almost
certainly are various other good
arguments as everyone we certainly are
not and I'm not really sure which one to
believe however well I can certainly say
is that the answer to that question very
much determines my answer to the
question are we learn the cosmos if
we're not in a simulation then we're
almost certainly nothing alone in the
cosmos but if we are in a simulation
then we could perfectly well be alone
only on TV I did however make Colbert
laugh when I was on Colbert Ian I know
right yeah I told him he said something
like you know wow we're gonna you know
we're not gonna cross the street are we
we're gonna have a curtal you're gonna
feel that we're risking so many years of
life if we take any risks right I said
no it's gonna be fine you're gonna be a
grandmother's gonna be able to help you
across the street cuz your grandmother's
struggle to be healthy and and he
actually thought that was quite funny so
I have the distinction of being one of
the few people who've actually made
Colbert laugh on stage so with your
answers right and to follow up with some
of my thoughts on it if the universe is
13.8 billion years old
and if
the earth is about four and a half
billion years old and if humans evolved
from primates about six million years
ago and if we planted food next to our
homes agriculture ten thousand years ago
and if fifty years ago we had pong
little dot and little two little sticks
outside and now we have virtual
realities that are almost completely
indistinguishable from normal reality
they're getting there we're getting
there very quickly hmm so that's such a
small period of time compared to the
relative length of cosmic existence but
also this your vastness of cosmic
existence about every fifth star when on
every five stars has an earth-like
planet in the habitable zone but we
could mount a simulation let go just go
a little pictures right you guys might
not be able to see it but refinishes
that no no like I said I don't know
whether we're in a simulation I think
they're a good argument from both sides
of that question okay okay but I'll
finish finish the thought just though
there's a little bit further so not only
is it the time of the cosmos but it's
also the vastness of the cosmos and
taking those things into account is
pointing us more and more in the
direction of not being alone in the
cosmos if we're not in a simulation yes
and that's good
and the Venn likelihood of there being
others in the cosmos then it makes it
like the earth that we are in a
simulation because it takes such a small
period of time for a race to gain enough
intelligence to be able to and
using our power from the star power from
quantum mechanics to be able to then
simulate a reality are we following yeah
what you guys alright we have an
audience question let's go ahead and
take it
look you've got another I think what I'm
saying by taking the microphone back is
yes we get the idea all right it's a
very valid point very point just to
answer that quick is when we are placing
you heard of Solace ISM the idea that we
can't trust it anything besides
ourselves is actually real so the going
going off of that a little bit further
you don't know that some things real
estate touch it therefore or see it or
whatever therefore we don't know China
is eternal so the point is that only
what needs to be simulated for that
brain is just that brain and that brains
body and then besides that everything
else only as they encounter it needs to
be simulated so it actually does not
require as much computing power was that
along oh yeah obviously the computing
power aspect is irrelevant because you
know we can in that we're not saying any
stopping point there there's plenty of
ways to get more computing power and
other civilizations they're only
slightly more advanced than ourselves
we'll have much more computing power and
so on so that's that's all kind of fine
you know of course you know quite right
that today is virtual reality is very
primitive indeed compared to what we
would need for any kind of world in
which we could think that we were part
of a simulation unless we go in the
scientistic direction but but that
doesn't take away at all from I mean it
doesn't really prove that we're in
relation or anything like that and in
fact you know where I thought you were
going with all of this with the firm
with the funny part but the funny part
paradox has plenty of answers that don't
involve us being a simulation like the
Fermi filters well right so actually
they that means that there's space
there's potential filters that cause a
civilization from being able to evolve
to a point where they could then gained
enough power to simulate as in something
like mutually assured destruction nuking
everyone or potentially disease
spreading or so by far my favorite of
the various traditional answers to the
Fermi paradox is the cloaking one that
essentially sure okay so plenty of
civilizations may get to the point where
they [ __ ] themselves laughing but the
fact is also there are various
civilizations that get to the point of
figuring out how not to blow themselves
up but they also recognize that some
other civilizations may be not very
peaceful and may be willing to go and
mess people up right and colonize the
force for example yeah that's right
and the best way not to be colonized
with force is not to be noticed now of
course today we are aware that we are
pumping out you know radio wave stuff
this rather rather indicative of our
intelligence rather fast into it's not
about having radio transmission yeah you
know at the moment but it's not obvious
that we weren't necessarily need to be
doing that we could quite possibly get
to a situation where we could do
everything we wanted to do down here and
the radio waves we're not getting out
and if that were true we might feel that
we were safer from other civilizations
so one perfectly good explanation for
the Fermi paradox is that there are
better civilization civilizations out
there that have survived perfectly well
for a nice long time but they don't want
anyone to know that they exist so we use
the power of something even much power
well how many whould so somewhat alien
civilization looks through a telescope
at our earth and rather than seeing
little tiny ants that are humans they
see very bland I'll remember that's not
quite how it's done right I'm not
talking about cloaking the I'm not going
about cloaking at the visual spectrum
I'm talking about cloaking at the level
of the radiation that the plant emits
into space that goes arbitrarily far out
right so you could imagine you can
imagine that you know some advanced
civilization if it got close enough
could have a look and you know that's
right but they'd have to take the
trouble to fly by right yeah right and
the question is which of the which of
them which was a very large number of
planets that exist might they bother to
fly by and the answer is the ones that
are emitting radio waves yeah that would
be easiest yeah
it's easiest to discover other species
the extension of what I'm saying that
you put forward is perfectly reasonable
we might end up cloaking a bit more you
know and and doing the kind of thing you
say you know there's nothing
particularly difficult about that all
right does anyone have a thought about
yeah I see a hand over here how separate
why don't you necessary is to achieve
that do you think that it is sufficient
for sort of private sector efforts that
are already aimed in this area do you
think
Behrman programs incentivizing perhaps
basic research and academia do you think
that it even needs to go further than
that that we need to have some sort of
national coordinated efforts like the
Manhattan Project okay great yeah yeah
sure I'll try and give us a reasonably
concise answer to that it's gonna be
hard actually cutting your funding
across everything so the first thing I
want to say is I believe that we do
basically know what needs to be done I
believe that this has overwhelmingly
transitioned at this point from a
scientific area in which the right thing
to do is more discovery of a much more
understanding of stuff to a
technological area in which the right
thing to do is to address these things
like engineers and to build stuff from
what we know already obviously that will
entail finding stuff most about us any
pioneering technology always does but it
will be driven by prior structure a
prior understanding of what's likely to
be the general pathway towards success I
think that's where we are right now
so then what that means in terms of the
you know the societal aspects that you
mentioned is how hard is it how
expensive is it all that kind of stuff
and for sure right now it's the need is
not good really you know we are we have
far too little money and of course I
mean I'm talking locally I and the chief
science officer of acara tick or fence
Research Foundation we have our energies
we only have four million dollars a year
you know that is pitiful well the good
news is that we only really need one
more digit on that you know
well [ __ ] I mean think about that funny
is that compared to the
military-industrial complex there's so
many possible or even medical research
in one country okay that's the only I
believe that if we had just one more did
you on top of our budget then we would
no longer have financial analyst repairs
on it over time to potentially restore
the body's homeostatic capacity to and
13-year old age yeah well so that's
that's a rather different question let
me kind of kind of finish that question
first strategies themselves totally I
mean I will explain in a minute why I
say that we have really to a good extent
transition from the discovery stage to
the engineering stage but yeah in terms
of where we are with the engineering you
know a lot of it is still at a very
early stage in other words it's not in
clinical trials or anything it's just
doing lab work you know with cells and
with mice and so on which is not really
not all that expensive and that's why I
can talk about these small numbers you
know and once those experiments get to a
certain level of proof of concept of
course the credibility increases the
money that's needed to go further to go
into clinical trials and so on it's
greater but it's much easier to get that
money because people understand that it
might actually work right so now I can
know that they Roofing so for those of
you don't know about 17 years ago I
first put forward the idea that we might
be able to address the problem of aging
in a manner that had previously been
kind of instinctively rejected by the
scientific community the scientific
community understood very well that
aging is caused by the progressive
accumulation of damage in the body
molecular cellular changes that
accumulate and progress through our time
and eventually that they get to a point
where the body is not set up to tolerate
them and the overall physical and mental
function that we have declines and
eventually face is entirely any
in three words metabolism causes alcohol
yeah yeah yeah that's the one I guess
yeah I know Willy is [ __ ] I know Billy
is five words because Klaus isn't one of
them you say I said metabolism causes
damage causes pathology and the key
thing is the metabolism causes damage
throughout life even something before
were born
whereas damage only causes pathology
late in life because the body is set up
to tolerate a certain amount of damage
before any pathology emerges and that's
really important what it means is that
on the one hand you definitely don't
want to be attacking the pathologies
directly because it's gonna inevitably
become harder and harder to do that is
the amount of damage you have the thing
that's causing the pathologies increases
but also it's really really hard to
clean up our metabolism and slow down
the rate at which it creates damage
because I metabolism is such a mess you
know anyone who writes software will
understand very well that if you look at
a metabolic chart it's the you know it's
the ultimate catastrophe of uncommented
spaghetti code so so so it's not gonna
happen you're not gonna be able to tweak
that just to make it work better clip
more cleanly but we can do instead is
neither of those things instead you can
go in and periodically repair the damage
preventatively in other words before
there's so much damage that it has
already caused pathology and if you're
repairing it reasonably well then you
can keep its overall level down below
the threshold that's bad for you even
without having any doing anything about
the rate at which the damage is being
being created in the first place so
leave ugly obvious to any engineer right
this is what we already did okay as the
car is starting to
[Music]
you want to intervene and had some new
solid parts of it so much part of the
problem I had when I started putting
these ideas across to my colleagues in
the biology of Aging was understanding
how in Christ's name they could not get
this you know it was well I mean this is
normal you expect that that's whenever
you have some kind of radical new way of
looking at a problem that the people who
are familiar with the old way dusty are
really set innate it took a while but we
got there you know after a decade or
more you know at this point most people
who work in the biology of Aging have
understood what I've been saying all
this time well enough that it has become
pretty much Orthodox people are even
reinventing the idea of pretending it's
original you know it's good well okay
first of all let me briefly explain what
I escape velocity is because many people
here so this is a term that I also I
also coined a long long time ago now
essentially I noticed I pointed out in
I'm gonna say so probably 2004 that
rejuvenation therapies the things I'm
talking about damage repair therapies by
time if you can do reasonably
comprehensive damage repair so that you
can keep people healthy for maybe 20 or
30 years longer than they normally would
be
then you've bought yourself all that
time you can apply those therapies to
someone it's already let's say 60 in
other words they're not very far away
from getting the pathologies of old age
as a result of having too much damage
you can take them back in in biological
aging other words in the amount of
damage that they're carrying so they
won't have that same amount of damage
again until they're let's say
chronologically 90 now they will
eventually they will get that kind of
damage at chronologically 90 even if
you're using these therapies every week
simply because the therapies won't be
perfect but in those 30 years we'll have
our chance to improve the therapies to
make them more comprehensive
they're 100% comprehensive initially
they still won't be but they'll be
closer to 100% that comprehensive so
some of the damage that the first
generation therapist didn't work on the
second generation will work on so we
will be able to reroute even eight the
same people at the age of 90 when
they're chronologically 60 for the
second time so there won't be
chronologically 60 for the third time
until it's re piloting 60 for the third
time until they're chronologically
hundred and fifty or whatever now so
that's that's one cavity escape velocity
essentially the I defined it as the
minimum rate at which we need to improve
the comprehensiveness of the therapies
in order to stay one step ahead of the
problem all right so the question was
how much would it cost to actually get
that now the reason we announced in that
question is whose money are we talking
about I at this point I'm the chief
scientist and the founder of a charity
that works on stuff that's so
early-stage that even most investors in
Silicon Valley regarded as too you know
too early too uncertain it's called
cents Research Foundation and the thing
is we do make progress with a relatively
small number of dollars that we are able
to attract over the time that we have
existed we've been able to push a number
of our projects far enough along that we
were able to spin them out and startup
companies we've done that five times now
and there's a couple more coming and you
know that's what we want to do first of
all because it demonstrates that we are
actually making progress
second of all because it brings money in
from sources that wouldn't otherwise do
so there's a lawful lot of people in
this place and around the rest of the
world for that matter who are very
supportive of this mission verbally and
who you know who have a lot of money but
who just don't like giving money away
and so they wait until there's an
investment opportunity even if it's a
very high-risk high-reward investment
opportunity they wait to that now we can
give them that so that is making things
better at this point it is that
obviously still absolutely essential to
maintain the foundation the
profit at the engine room of all of that
the organization that actually does the
stuff that is still at - earliest age
for even the most visionary investors to
get involved and that's why I spend my
time you know trying to try my best to
make that happen
but you know things are getting better
so the answer to your fundamental
question is that's the first step and
it's very small amounts of money its
order of you know eight digits per year
but then when we get the next step
towards clinical trials it's gonna be
know billions per year but that's gonna
be much easier to get it won't be our
money it'll be the money a big farm at
the money of governments and so on and
then to get you know anywhere beyond
that to put it combine all these things
together which is ultimately the last
step to get longevity escape velocity
that will be the easy part that will be
the easiest of all because we will be
simply doing so yeah the regulatory part
will pretty much be another by that and
really just combining multiple things
that are already individually improved
well I mean the thing is I love said you
know you have to take it in multiple
steps so I mean the first step is I said
I've tended to talk about it's this
thing not like a schedule of things but
rather robust mouth rejuvenation so I
defined that a long time ago as taking
middle aged mice of a reasonably long
live healthy strain that would normally
live to let's say three years without
any intervention do nothing whatsoever
to them until they're already two years
old so they're definitely a middle a
literature to the west through their
life do how I do stuff to them then that
gets them to live to five years an
average rather than only three that's
like that's the way that's the best of
the somewhat arbitrary numbers that I
chose for my definition vector I believe
that we could get to that with the kind
of money I was talking about earlier the
kind of 40 or 50 million dollars per
year and when I started saying that ten
years ago or more I said it was going to
take about ten years and we're not there
believe it or not but that's of course
we haven't had the 40 million year
would we make those same changes very
much the same yes I mean in fact well
we've got these seven different major
categories of damage that I always talk
about these are very big categories they
sound a little bit like so big that they
wouldn't be useful but they are useful
so one is loss of cells cells dying and
not being automatically replaced by the
division of other cells so you know that
happens in a lot of different ways a lot
of different places in the body during
aging and it causes problems of course
but you might think well so it's such a
broad category why is it even useful to
define it the answer is because the
answer the repair strategy for all such
cases is broadening the same it's stem
cell therapy that's what you do you know
you Bertie pre-program yourselves in the
lab so that when you inject them into
the body they know what to do they know
how to divide and transform themselves
into replacements for the cells that the
body is not replacing on its own and of
course different stem cell therapies for
different tissues are different but
they're only different in their details
that have a huge amount in common so
once you've got stem cell therapy
working really well for one condition
in one tissue the amount of work that's
involved to get it for work to work for
the second one the third one far less
that's why it's useful to have this
classification this taxonomy in its
strategy cool good questions from the
audience we do need to move forward and
continue into this into a similar
category I'm not gonna go for your
bucket list well I mean one good welcome
what's the point of monogamy whether or
not we're
well hey I merged in case in point
because I spent 18 years being
monogamous and then eight years being
poly and now I'm monogamous again you
know it's just like I go oh and that was
all my choice by the way it's not
looking everybody alright I'm going to
pick this question because I think it's
important to address it before the end
of the evening this question is do you
believe genetic engineering and neural
prosthetics will exacerbate wealth
inequality know that and the main reason
I don't is because the main way in which
genetic engineering and indeed neural
prosthesis but let's take for definite
carry except for in my the main way in
which those things will benefit anybody
will be in relation to age-related
problems in other words as a large
component of the kind of work that we
work on its ass it's the development of
ways to keep people youthful in old age
and I believe that that entire corpus of
medical interventions and it comes
online is going to be viewed and treated
by society very very differently from
the high-tech medicine that we see today
the high-tech medicine we see today of
course does exhibit it's not a class
about a lot of inequality simply because
it's really expensive well if we depend
on stem cell quite a lot yeah it's not
available to everybody by any man think
that it's not really a good example
because hardly any stem cell therapies
are actually approved yet anyway but
things that are approved but
expensive you know the supply thing is
that these therapies that are expensive
and only limited very limited
availability overwhelmingly aggressing
whether or another condition associated
with aging simply because you know or
whatever taking medicine you know
addressing aging certainly because we
fix everything else already more or less
um and that means pretty much by
definition it doesn't work right the
best that you can get from anything that
addresses an age related condition today
is a very modest performant of the ill
health that was going to happen anyway
which means that the economic arithmetic
is crap it means that basically you're
gonna be pumping a large amount of money
into somebody to keep them a little bit
healthier for a little bit longer and
then you're gonna be spending the same
amount of money that you were going to
anyway to keep them alive in a declining
state of health and now they're going to
die you know so you've basically
achieved nothing for your money except a
very mild amount of quality of life okay
wait whereas if you had therapies that
actually worked for aging the situation
would be completely different now I'm
not even talking here about the
humanitarian imperative I'm talking
about pure hustling mercenary economic
logic from that purely economic point of
view aging is ridiculously expensive
I mean 90% of our medical care goes on
Aging and that's of course just a direct
cost that's not even counting the you
know the lost productivity
kids are the elderly are looking after
their parents or the fact that the
elderly are no longer contributing
wealth to society because they're not
well enough to do that you know all that
kind of stuff right so if we fix all
that then the country is gonna be vastly
more prosperous well that but
fundamentally can be stayed as is these
therapies will pay for themselves at the
national level ridiculously many times
over ridiculously rapidly and another
way of saying it is if one country
decides to make these things available
through taxation their respective
ability to pay and other country does
the opposite then the country that does
the opposite is going to be bankrupt
extremely foods okay so you know I know
this sounds very content to give an
alien into a u.s. audience good you guys
grew up being you know not very being
terribly fond of this thing called
taxation but the fact is but the fact is
you already have a president it's just
that the precedent is not high-tech
medicine the precedent is basic
education now I mean basic I know
obviously better education is too basic
we know that but the fact is everybody
gets it for free and the reason why that
is not a political football is simply
because everybody ultimately understands
that if you don't give your kids at
least some basic education then twenty
years down the road the country going
bankrupt because you're not gonna be
able to make anything or do anything
yeah all these teeny tedious chronically
old people who are irritatingly not
dying right speaking of speaking of
someone who is in danger of being
irritatingly not dying before you it's
perfectly simple I mean I think this
again is something that I've been saying
since [ __ ] forever and nobody [ __ ]
remember so I mean look it's very simple
Oh population is not a function of how
many people we have on the planet it's a
function of the difference between how
many people we have on the planet and
how many people we can have on the
planet with an acceptable level of
environment
in that measure whatever way you like
climate change whatever right and forget
that second number is another constant
it's not like it's not like like you
know the speed of light it's not
something that's a universal physical
like immutable it changes as a result of
other technologies hello we're the girls
and these technologies that are being
developed in this town you know solar
energy you know artificial means
you know dissemination these are the
things that are going to increase the
carrying capacity of the planet and if
you even think about it it's completely
[ __ ] obvious that these things are
going to increase the carrying capacity
is right far faster than the population
of the planet could possibly increase
even if we completely make it all death
from all causes now supposedly so I've
said this before speak about genetic
engineering from an intelligence
perspective speak about it from making
intelligence that it's about metabolism
edits as in how will that not increase
well again it depends why we do it you
know this is kind of related to the into
the old age old question of therapy
versus enhancement you know what is the
difference between therapy and how at
the end of the day it's a question of
how much we believe that we ought to
have such a thing you know and that
comes because the card you see that
comes from how much we observe that some
people already have the thing so for
example young people young adults today
tend not to have outsiders disease
therefore we regard anything that starts
old people from getting out time disease
and the therapy young people today do
not have wings
therefore we regard giving people of any
age wings as an enhancement right you
know simple as that ready now now
another thing is both of these things
could in principle be achieved by
genetic engineering right so you can't
go say engineering either gonna crease
here not because it's depends on how
it's used way to use for and how we
think about the thing that we're
thinking of using it for correct and so
in the case of wanting a amplifier
child's intelligence or tabble ISM and
not costing a hundred thousand dollars
well yeah I mean so you know what is
well okay so first of all we're not
really anyway I mean
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
lately that's right okay well we go do
you believe there is a difference
between life and non-life well certainly
there is no difference when it comes to
aging the aging of machines in relation
to angel Atreus aging of machines that
we unequivocally and universally view as
alive such as ourselves is the
fundamental level indistinguishable from
aging of machines that we universally
view is not alive like cars of course
the details are different because the
details of the structure and composition
of these different machines is different
but that's true between different
machines that are not living or
different machines that are living so
whether it's alive or not it again not a
distinction it's very very important to
understand that aging is a phenomenon of
physics and not a phenomenon of biology
because that's the first step in
demystifying it getting people to
understand and it's not this enigma that
we have to just kind of live with
biology I mean biological machines live
in the physical universe so obviously
that means that anything that's a
phenomenon of biology is also a
phenomenon of physics but the point is
that things that are phenomena of
physics might be viewed as not really
fully explaining phenomena of biology
the biology would be some kind of emerge
phenomenon and the question is is aging
one of those things and the answer is no
aging it's fundamentally a simple thing
that's easily understood and it's
fundamentally the same for non living
machines there is for living machines
and is there then a line between life
and not life do you call certain things
without life so of course this age-old
question you know people have it's
really you know it really ultimately
comes down as so many philosophical
questions due to a matter of definition
you know people can perfectly well make
perfectly good parsimonious definitions
of life that say the viruses are alive
and people can also make equally
parsimonious once the salad fire is not
alive and I don't give a damn the fact
is the fact is I'm a practical guy I
don't care about philosophy I care about
suffering correct and eradicating that
suffering but also the philosophy around
these things is crucially important
through the progress of the world no
it's not no no the understanding that
the philosophy of these things is not
greatly important to the world ok
executing but if there is not
conversation being had amongst people
about how it's going to impact the world
that's that's sociology and politics and
stuff like that yeah so philosophy the
so-called ethics of all this type of
stuff is that that the things that come
under that category I think like the
question there they essentially the
death gives meaning to life you know
other [ __ ] of that nature right
whereas questions like well we put all
the people that's not a philosophical
question that's a sociological question
okay
genetic engineering neural prospects I
think this is in sense a philosophical
question well I guess so again so again
so it's so again as I said genetic
engineering could be can be you know the
the merits of it can be a philosophical
question but not in total you have you
can only answer those questions if you
look at how you're going to use them and
how you could use them so insofar as
they are being used in so far as the
particular technology is being used for
therapeutic purposes for purposes which
nobody disputes are purely therapeutic
rather than enhancement or anything like
that and furthermore purposes which are
going to be with high probability
available to everybody you know the
so-called ethical questions that might
surround such applications of such
technology just disappear whereas if the
same technology is proposed to be used
for other purposes like for example
giving people wings or gills or whatever
right and this is not perceived as an
essential human right and not made
available to everybody because society
doesn't vote for it right then you could
say well okay that's a different ethical
question all right I mean
[Music]
there's a guy over there at the Blish is
really desperate to have a question Wow
no okay
okay in that case just regularly
intertwined okay so the things that I
view as ethics rather than sociology
things that are not tied to the real
world
so when leon kass I think he was the
first person sage says death gives
meaning to life you know there's nothing
to tie it to it's a it's an assertion
what the [ __ ] you know how can well
actually argue that question it's
completely it lives in a vacuum where
the question about overpopulation or you
know weaponry or whatever this is a
question that the question changes
depending on what you can do so with my
own stable population question as you've
heard which some people mistakenly call
an ethical question is a technological
answer right I say hello we're not going
to have this problem because we've got
all these other technologies that are
going to increase the carrying capacity
of the planet so it's suddenly
miraculously no longer an ethical
question which to me means it never
wasn't ethical question no this guy's
here the writer I take the view that
people are overly afraid of the unknown
and if a new technologies but only to a
point
I believe that people overuse the
precedent of nuclear weapons as a
warning against developing new
technology saying
better not develop such and such a thing
because really to my mind the only way
that any new technology can be a bad
idea to develop is if it fulfills three
criteria number one why shell said in
one sentence the criteria are basically
that the technology has to be something
that can be used by a small number of
people to do a large amount of damage in
a very small amount of time if if any
one of those three things is not the
case then you basically don't have a
problem you know the society can control
the use of the technique misuse of the
technology no biological weapons for
very much at least potentially under the
same category of nuclear weapons oh of
course it's not the weapons but I mean
in some cases nuclear weapons are bad
but nuclear power might be good right so
in this case similarly bad I think that
was Oh exactly
exactly that was kind of a bad thing
right I mean of course we did it because
we wanted to feature power whatever it
was but but yeah so biological weapons
absolutely especially today when things
are so much cheaper and easier to get
you know it's a big problem but the
point is it's a big problem anyway you
don't have to have the additional
motivation of developing such and such a
technology that comes from the wish to
defeat aging in order to have that
problem so the only way to address that
problem is to you know have quest
monitoring and so on and have access to
this or this or that you know it's tough
anyway you know that's how he's being
developed whatever yep
dr. Joe I think it'll be good fun for me
to tweet the fact that Rhys Jones asked
me the question question is do you
believe anthropogenic global warming is
causing catastrophic climate change well
of course it is the question is the
question is what we are focusing so
here's a problem that I've had with the
climate change people over the years
people who have been trying to make a
big noise about climate change and
trying to fix it to my mind they haven't
really been terribly efficient and
effective about pinpointing the thing
they need to be focusing on the focus
has so much been on the fact that it was
our fault that we did it you know that
the climate change is happening and it's
as a result of what we're doing who
gives a damn whether we did it what
matters is that it's bad for us now and
we need to fix it even if we didn't do
it we should still fix it hello it turns
out that stopping doing what we have
been doing is not actually going to
contribute very well to fixing the
problem what we really need is totally
new technology for carbon sequestration
and such like that will fix the problem
and if we get really good at that kind
of stuff then we can carry on doing this
so-called bad stuff that way we don't
you thought incomprehensible level of
incomprehension from from climate change
people when I went to when I went to try
to point this out Audrey have we
measured enough variables to determine
that catastrophic climate change is
occurring to the planet look god we
bloody are we oh we have okay so how
have we have we measured
proximity of the star to the earth have
we measured the amount of Sun flares on
the earth
well the help I got a day with yeah yeah
yeah right yeah I know that the whole
bunch of stupid you know did we land on
the moon kind of arguments that say that
say that some doubt about this but the
bleeding obviously isn't you know I mean
you know there may be doubts about the
second order you know whether it's
speeding up you know how rapidly it's
reaching some kind of catastrophic point
and obviously people are finding out
things all the time about exactly the
you know the dynamics of ice holes in
the Antarctic and such like that are
helping us to predict things better and
this again is what I say you know who
gives a [ __ ] the fact is even if there
is some merit to these questions as to
the extent to which the climate change
we're seeing is anthropogenic we still
got a bloody fix the thing if we don't
want to drown yes no no carbon
sequestration that's what we've got it's
not good its damage repair for [ __ ]
sake that is carbon sequestration you
know that was the next question by the
way did you pull the thing out of the
bucket in your hand alright what was the
question again
do you believe artificial intelligence
the controversial beyond this some of
you probably know that I used to work in
artificial intelligence before I was a
biologist I did that I worked in
software verification for six seven
years and I you know I've had good
fortune to be good friends with quite a
lot of the pioneers in our speciality
especially these days I knew a 90's
obviously head of deepmind since he was
an undergrad and he's definitely one of
my big heroes right now but yeah so do I
think it has a risk I do but I think the
risk is probably rather low but I want
to preface my explanation for that with
an absolutely huge caveat
this is 100 percent out of my ass
intuition it's absolutely not based on
any kind of real evidence evidence-based
rationale I just think that the thing
that people are most scared about which
is recursive self-improvement where
machines get to a point of sufficient
autonomy and sufficient self
comprehension sufficient understanding
of their own workings that they can
improve themselves without human
intervention or despise human
intervention I think that that may
genuinely be impossible in practical
terms because it's too IO bound possible
to achieve yes why because it may be to
i/o bound in other words I input upper
bound what their will that means in
computer could be the people here will
understand what that means but so what
that means is simply the amount of
interaction the amount of data transfer
between the machine that's doing the
improvement and its environment has to
be too great the amount of that data
transfer has to will limit the rate at
which the thing can improve it can
determine how whether it is improving
itself and therefore how to improve
itself so if you look at for example
recent advances any experiments that the
machine can do any in a certain amount
of time so if we look at myself yes but
only as a result of the data no well yes
but not yes sure it can make its data if
you make it a choice of what experiment
to do more efficient but that reaches
diminishing returns in like that's my
intuition the
so we don't see that when we look at
deep my alphago ability to teach
yourself out of my gut because there
there's no IO need it it's purely
thinking it's purely playing something
against itself I mean
purely formal system where the rules are
just mathematics is there an existential
threat artificial intelligence leaders
of the United States and our
intelligence leaders of China are
attempting to maximize their economic
success
oh sure I mean don't get me wrong I
think there's plenty of danger from the
the the the the advances of artificial
intelligence technology in general
whether you call it a GI or not being
lumpy being non uniformly distributed
and being misused by that person but
that's a whole smaller problem than the
hypothetical problem of recursive
self-improvement if it did then I think
we would have a very big problem but I
don't I have a thick my my gut feeling
is that it's never gonna be a problem
because it just can't be done so if we
leave request enough improvement out of
it and we just look at what think things
that I do think can be done right then I
think the I think it's there is nothing
special about it
the distinguish it from other aspects of
technological progress yes it needs to
be monitored it needs to be developed
responsibly and disseminated responsibly
just like any other new technology in
order to have the best you know benefits
for Humanity but I don't think there's
nothing special about it well to develop
it as far as possible because ultimately
secure things ultimately technologies
are you know they give people more
choice more options and therefore more
potential for quality and quantity of
life but dissemination responsibly you
know and and effectively and safely
earth giving people having the right
having respecting society's opinion as
to risk benefit ratio
you know things like that and you call
that sociological and I call that
philosophical yeah we could begin to go
political as well but it's definitely
not philosophy it's definitely on ethics
definitely not ethics that's right it's
not when you talk about building and
artificial intelligence there's no
there's no ethics as you're executing
this into the world what are the ethics
what are these discussions then they're
sociological discussions they're not
basically that's true yes I think that
at the end of the day when you can
reduce a so-called ethical question to a
technological sociological question a
question of how the circuit the specific
concrete circumstances in which the
availability of this or that technology
would be good and the availability isn't
there so nicely which it would not be
good then it's no longer an ethical
question it's a sociological question a
technological one I think philosophical
questions are ones that are not tied to
reality but again again I again I again
I give the exam I give the example of
Cassie's statement death gives me to
life how the hell are we supposed to
evaluate the truth or falsity of that
statement you know that is ethics to me
okay okay one have no green one yet
I want to hear hang on all right do you
believe that you this is a very tedious
question do you believe that human
immortality is feasible okay so I guess
I'm gonna have to have bloody have a bit
of a rant about the word immortality
somebody is is holding up his hand as if
to say we only have five minutes left
that would you say well
alright let me do the plenty of
mortality Nelson's vest
all right so never ever ever when you're
trying to persuade someone that they
might be a little bit overly fatalistic
about aging never ever let the word
immortality enter the conversation if
anybody sounds to you oh I don't want to
live forever the first thing you need to
say is
[ __ ] hell we're not talking about
living forever we're talking about not
getting outside of these boys and girls
okay everything that you have ever seen
written about me in the mainstream media
that focuses on me being called the
prophet of immortality or you know or
even talking about living forever or
even longevity at all is a
misrepresentation that is done purely to
sell papers I can't stop people doing it
if they just to sell papers at the end
of the day it's better for me to get
publicity of some kind University at all
so I've got to do it
but the fact is it's a misrepresentation
we don't work on that I don't work on
that I've never worked on that I've
never believed that it makes sense to
think about the idea of immortality at
all or even the idea of longevity as a
goal for its own sake I have always
believed that the right thing to be
thinking about is keeping people healthy
because nobody wants to be sick and it
just happens that not being sick has a
side effect that you're more likely to
wake up tomorrow morning if you're not
sick today we know how it feels when
when we're sick it feels like misery and
living healthy and happy feels
incredible good okay so to immortality
is not the right way to talk about it
there's a better way to talk about it so
okay so I could answer the question do I
believe that an indefinite youthful life
is feasible in other words do I believe
that we can get into a state where we do
not in extra
we become sicker on average the longer
ago we were born and absolutely I
believe that we are almost there I
believe that within the next couple of
decades we have a very good chance at
least a 50-50 chance of achieving that
goal great all right we will have a
little bit of Q&A a couple more thoughts
next question do you believe universal
basic income can sustain a post it's an
interesting concept I mean I believe
that the concept of universal basic
income as it's currently described it's
probably only a first step a very kind
of you know blunt instrument in terms of
how we can structure a society that is
not built around the concept of the
ideal of full employment and I certainly
do believe that the rate at which
automation is coming is such that there
is no way in hell that we will be able
to pull the rabbit out of the Hat in
terms of full employment that we did
last time around you know by inventing
the you know this enormous service
sectors to take up the slack from the
loss of jobs in manufacturing and
agriculture at the end of the day you
know what's the left this you know it's
basically the entertainment industry how
many you know footballers and fingers do
you need not even anymore because music
right whether it whether
yeah well yeah I mean I believe that
there's a bunch of truth in the idea
that people will continue to pay for
things where it is precisely the fact
that it's another person doing it that
they're paying for but not a dog - no
that's not one of the example but a
comedian a comedian quite possibly a
musician I think it'll pay less I think
they would actually prefer a beautician
that they feel is there has some kind of
energy with that's my point I think so
there will be still be money in the
cemetery but you only need so many of
them and you know so I can certainly
pursue it conceive of a future not very
far away you know a couple of decades in
which work as a whole as in stuff that
you get paid to do that you wouldn't do
otherwise can become something that we
could compare with conscription
you know something that young adults are
forced to do for a short while you know
as part of education or as part of their
contribution society and once they're
done they never have to do it again and
everything's free you know I think
that's a very realistic scenario not
very far into I'm just well I feel I can
do is to draw the broad strokes of how
we should be thinking about these
questions how we should be you know
juxtaposing different input different
that new data that we have let's to
colonizing Mars all right should we
colonize Mars globally or nationally I'm
gonna dad loves an unpleasant place I
mean you know you know I'm all for that
I'm not the kind of existential risk
type who says that you know it's
absolutely pivotal that we should
maintain the species or cost him one way
or another
III can't tend to be the kind of person
who thinks that almost everybody dying
is almost as bad as everybody dying but
nevertheless I'm all for not everybody
dying and so absolutely it would be nice
to have off planet civilizations but I
wouldn't try Mars I would build a much
more controlling but yeah and yeah that
kind of thing yeah that further away
than the
millions of not the point he doesn't
make millions in order to preserve the
species do I need a fear and so oh so
you'd want to throw up a hundred
thousand in there and then just in case
if something was to happen on people who
have [ __ ] up enough to want to live in
space right you know when one hears that
musk is finding a number of people you
have to go to Mars and never come back
right well quite quite but the point is
like I mean this question often gets
melt melded wrongly in my view with the
question of mass immigration as though
as an approach to the other population
problem that we discussed alright well
now how about the slow and steady tear
formation of Mars over time - and then
all the people that you call stupid
would stay on earth there you go and you
can go to Mars and all smart people I'll
stay on earth with all the smart people
and all the stupid people yeah okay what
about that positive vision and
furthermore back to the question
specifically Aubrey is do you do you
believe in the national progress of
going and building space missions and
going to the moon and stuff like that or
do you believe in it being a more global
effort well of course at the moment it's
increasingly neither is increasingly a
private-sector thing I don't see any
problem with that
yeah it's fostering a lot of innovation
definitely yes and I want to piggyback
on this question with a new question
it's not on this list but the question
is do you believe in world peace oh no I
think was great okay that's opposed to
me do I think that world peace is
possible Wow
actually I said something about this I'm
on a decade ago when I spoke at Ted I
say well I can't speaking to this bunch
of
people who have a high opinion of you
know their ability to influence the
world and in many cases that opinion is
justified and you know what we want to
do is exploit what I want to do is kind
of capitalize on that can-do attitude
and get people to really get motivated
and what I chose to do in my TED talk
was and this by the way in case you're
gonna be confused this is not the same
talk that on ted.com talk I have a comic
when I go but tEDGlobal in oh five I'm
talking about the talk I gave you know
six at the real time basically I said
listen if we actually crack this if we
bring aging under proper control it's
not just that we're going to not have
people with Alzheimer's disease I mean
that's awfully wonderful but the fact is
it's also going to help us to see that
we have as a populace of species the
ability to address and to really succeed
in addressing extremely hard problems
and I use World Peace is one of my
examples you know I think I probably use
climate change as well you know I think
I may be music wake so you know I said
like we know we got the early rain at
night I mean with nothing [ __ ]
together but we can work together with
to actually achieve something that we
have spent our entire histories through
that civilization believing was
impossible and World Peace is a fine
example of that there's a good of
empowerment statements something like
our way of something like world peace
[Music]
all right let's do and then we can cover
what women like and dislike about each
other
yes all right
let's wrap it by yourself all right
quick quick rapid-fire is DubLi nuclear
fusion community energy source for
civilization good yeah I mean it's
really exciting yeah this was rapid fire
all right do you believe in clean meat
is it feasible
you mean artificial me yeah yeah okay in
fact we were the first people to invest
in organovo the tissue and the tissue
printing company the organ burning
company which of course spun out what
the world's leading artificial make
company modern matter and next is do you
believe regulations put too much
restriction on innovation mm exactly on
innovation but on the dissemination of
innovation and I think that that's
definitely an argument that the risk
aversion of society in contaminates the
development of new technologies in the
dissemination of that access to those
technologies too much no not appreciably
maybe a little bit for some people but
not enough to be of much interest to me
okay and do you believe consciousness is
localized in the human nervous system
I've known it I don't give it out
because of the fact is it works you know
the body is the thing that doesn't that
stops working and the consciousness
works fine until the body doesn't
alright unless
questions from our audience all right
let's see have you thought about the
possibility that asking for forty to
fifty million dollars for biological
extension might be short-sighted given
40 to 50 billion dollars could solve the
merging with machines extending
consciousness themselves versus which
might be a possible stopgap biological
constant okay so what I'm feeling what
I'm feeling ornery and I hear a question
that starts with have you thought of
this
I generally also question by saying yes
I'm shutting up but today I'm feeling
charitable so I won't say that yeah all
right so I'm yeah so basically we never
know which technological approach is
going to solve a given knowledge problem
more most the most quickly and I I mean
even within the universe of biomedical
purely wet solutions to the problems of
Aging
we have sense Research Foundation oh
it's diverse as we can be weird are we
pursue alternative ways to do this or
that thing so I am a hundred percent in
favor of that same diversity in a wider
level where we just basically say you
know people ought to be working on
uploading as well as working on you know
the web version of what we're doing my
personal opinion has been an remains
that at this point the wet work is going
better and we're gonna get to longevity
escape velocity more rapidly with that
then we will with anything that involves
transfer of our consciousness to a more
robust hardware but I completely
acknowledge if I always have then I
could be wrong about that and I greatly
applaud the pursuit of the alternative
approaches and
course they funding of other parties and
it's nice that the people who tend to be
interested in these various approaches
tend to overlap I might think the best
way to do is have any very conventional
style because then people think well
he's not crazy he's very conventional
he's wearing suit he looks normal
because I should listen to this idea but
you obviously have a dramatically
unconventional style very important very
important question of course it's not
just a question for you know why do I do
things the way I do it's also question
for all of you here because I have a
perception that this is a very
sympathetic audience many of you may
want advice about how you can be better
advocates but make more of a difference
yourselves in that regard so yes very
important actually you know I couldn't
give a talk called how to be a
successful heretic which addresses some
of it online but yeah well let me tell
whether than try to go through all of
the things I say in that talk well do
it's just specifically address the
question you asked about war one of the
pros and cons about looking and
appearing unconventional and that is
actually a rather subtler question than
one might think
there are definitely downsides for
looking unconventional of the sort that
you just described
however they're also upsides that one
upside which is kind of generic
introspective of the course that one is
pursuing which is that it's very
important to be memorable you know it's
it's important to stick in some with
mine so they
the next time they say you in the media
they kind of remember what they saw only
kind of if you get you get a better
accumulation of appreciation of what was
said but the other thing which is
another thing which is very much
specific to the anti-aging world is that
I have to contend with the fact that
there is already an enormous history of
millennia of snake oil in this area of
people saying that they know how to fix
aging already and not being correct and
of course these days there is very
clearly an extremely large thing called
the anti-aging industry which is
entirely based on products that
fundamentally don't work so it's
extremely important for me to make it
very clear at the very first impression
to my audience that I'm not one of those
but I'm not in this in any way for
personal financial gain
and where you see it is the wrong way to
do that what about the actual strategies
of dissemination of topics that are kind
of radical that you want to change the
world with any recommendations for that
well right so that kind of come back to
the kind of whole slew of things that I
said in this how to be a successful
heretic to essentially basically what I
said words but my first one was be right
I think I said something like diligence
before oratory you know you know I mean
yeah Sean Carroll French physicist wrote
is a wonderful thing probably fifteen
years ago along those lines saying
almost all heretics are actually
heretics for a good reason you know
they're just not been careful than wrong
right so if you actually have a good
idea that's really radical you're yeah
the the odds are against you and
everybody knows it and you know then you
know be charismatic be funny be
everywhere you know go out and actually
talk to people you know all the obvious
things that I do you know and be
memorable
[Music]
[Music]
that's the end of that whether
metaphysics what so no I think I wasn't
clear I'm not saying that questions like
a certain like death gives me to life or
you know consciousness exists in the
brain well I'm not saying that those are
invalid questions I'm saying that they
are a different category of question
from questions like well we put all the
people they're not grounded in no
experiments that we can do no it's like
you know does God exist you know I think
that you know all those tons of
questions these are essentially outside
of the realm of scientific and
technological exploration they can yes
all the ones you I just said like that
does death give me to life or not does
God exist you know does consciousness
exist in the brain or not these things
that's true yeah I believe that the
definition of God okay so my way of
thinking about it is this
I say well okay consciousness is this
thing which is inherently an experience
that we have you know it's you could
call it a sixth sense you know we
experience our own thoughts in the same
way the experienced sights and sounds
and smells right now where this thing
come from
no I mean in the same way that we can't
know whether we're in a simulation we
can't know whether we are we can't we
can't say we can't falsify solipsism you
know similarly we can't say where that
sixth sensory input comes from so it's a
ridiculous question I mean it's not a
religious question it's a ridiculous
idea
we will be able to answer that question
by scientific experimentation or
observation no one has to know that
people including myself are going
especially oneself are going to think
that one has improved it that's a very
different thing so you know I know a lot
of people in the effective altruism
community for example and they know
first of all the whole bunch of you have
foundational questions about whether
utilitarianism is the right way to
measure marry yeah things like that I
mean that's very much a philosophical
question I say yeah you can't answer
that by experiment it's just a choice
right I mean I mean course one could I
whether utilitarianism is correct
choices are gonna mean more choice
worthy I don't understand that yes but
that's basically a hierarchy you can say
nothing wrong with there's nothing wrong
with it it's a different kind of thing
argumentation and experimentation are
very different processes argumentation
involves basically maths it's involved
in the abstract saying okay if we assume
this and we assume that then we can
infer the other and some such inferences
are not obvious and that's why
philosophy is an actual field right that
makes perfect I'm fine with that right
but that's no different from saying okay
it depends what choices of axioms of set
theory you use you can prove different
things depending on whether you like the
axiom of choice or nothing like that
right so entirely fine with that but
that's an entirely different thing from
what I actually care about I don't give
a flying [ __ ] whether the action is
right it's true I actually care about
whether I'm gonna get Alzheimer's
No so we'll have this conversation later
I want to Mike we got okay
Aubrey that's not sufficient so the [ __ ]
are you to tell me what you're buying my
next phase of that well okay first of
all to understand weather-wise in the
simulation that's something that very
much it falls into to my mind the
category of philosophy in other words at
this point we have no way even to go
about the question of designing an
experiment that would answer the
question now I will say that I don't
think that's a water-type answer that
it's conceivable to me that we might
come up with an actual solid argument
that would say that this particular
observation would demonstrate very
positively indeed that yes we are in
simulation or conversely we're not but
you know people who have thought about
this a lot you know for a living like
Nick Bostrom you know the best they've
been able to do and it's very good but
the best they've been able to do is to
come up with a very weak kind of thing
that says you know if such a thing is
true and when it in simulation if it's
not then we're not you know they
definitely haven't given us a decision
per path I hope paths are actually
coming to a conclusion and therefore I
would be off about if we ever do find to
the path to coming to that conclusion
from observation
up with an answer of whether we aren't
emulation then we could do scientific
experiments in order to figure out right
I mean everything in science ultimately
involves well if a at the bottom line
everything involves an alternation
between hypothesis formation and
hypothesis testing but that means that
you have to have some way into that
alternation process right so you have to
have if you if you can't figure out what
the first experiment is to do to even
get anywhere I'll shut up all right
[Music]
[Applause]